Today.
Let's just jump into the first question.
Do you know how many tourists there were
in 2017 all around the world?
Well,
listen,
now,
because this number may make more than
one of you jumped out of your chair.
According to data from the World Tourism
Organization,
no less than 1.3 billion people traveled
from 2017 yeah,
that's more than 1.3 billion
international tourists.
As you can imagine,
this gigantic industry generated more
than one point $2 trillion.
I want to,
we fines when there's so much business.
Well,
of course we find companies,
well in this video we're going to focus
on one company,
one that was founded in 2008 have two
young guys who couldn't even pay their
rents and switch in just 10 years became
one of the five largest tourist
corporations in the world.
I'm sure you all know it and I'm sure
many of you have actually used us
because of course we're talking about
Airbnb,
the largest accommodation company on the
planet did by Simon's loved by others.
So what's the Eir?
It's true dimensions whilst purpose is
it trying to achieve and what
implications does this have?
Well,
let's dive in,
shall we?
Yeah.
Everything that has to do with Airbnb is
pretty impressive and no,
I'm really not exaggerating.
Yeah.
Only being 10 years old,
Abbey and the has managed to become the
largest Chrism accommodation company in
the world.
In fact,
it sells more rooms than the next four
companies in the ranking combined,
Marriott,
Hilton and intercontinental and wisdom,
these are the four largest hotel chains
in the wells combined.
They have 3.3 million rooms.
Airbnb alone,
there's more than 4 million.
We're actually talking about almost 5
million rooms spread over more than 190
countries.
Through this platform.
We can book a room in more than 81,000
different cities.
These data,
you can imagine the huge panic that
heavy and B has caused in the boards of
directors of the largest hotel
companies.
Sure.
BNB is a mortal threat to the US hotel
industry.
Ian Schrager,
American entrepreneur hotelier and real
estate developer,
and you know,
the reality is while we have every
reason to panic since it was launched,
Airbnb as managed 300 million
reservations,
but if that sounds like a lot,
well,
keep listening because the numbers are
growing so fast is that the company
expects to surpass 1 billion
reservations as of 2028 a year.
Wow.
Before we continue,
there is
one note here.
As you may know,
most technology companies lose money,
sometimes a lot of money in the first
years.
This is because they have to spend a lot
to start up the company,
acquire technology,
build a brand,
get customers,
et cetera.
That's of course someone has to make
that investment because while at the end
of the day,
given minds that many times the founders
of these companies are students,
engineers,
designers,
etc. Generally young people who are not
exactly billion as,
that's why in silicon valley it's
practically throughout the entire
technological worlds.
There's an instrument that has become
something like the holy grail of the
industry.
That's the financing round.
Hello.
Let me to explain how this works.
A startup when it's not listed on the
stock market,
meets with a bunch of venture capital
investors and presents their projects
and then the investor or investors who
put money on the table or services such
as contacts and legal or technological
support,
they are given a part of the company and
when the startup needs more resources,
they have more financing rounds just
like this.
Yes.
And its latest financing round.
AIRBNB got $1 billion for about 3% of
its shares.
That means the investors valued the
entire company at $31 billion.
Not Bad for something that's 10 years
old.
Right.
You said that you might now be wondering
how enough did a company founded by two
young graduates managed to become such a
huge empire in such little time?
Well,
we're going to take a look at this and
where and how it all began.
And I'll tell you now that if the
current numbers are impressive,
that origins are not far behind.
So listen up
the roots.
I imagine it's the year 2007 and your 26
years old,
you've just finished your studies and
you've moved to seek your fortune in the
Capitol of technological
entrepreneurship,
San Francisco.
But of course you've got to pay a lot's
to live in such a fashionable city,
so you get an apartment for $1,200 a
month,
which you can still barely a force.
The question is,
well,
what would you do now?
Yeah,
well that's precisely the question that
Brian Chesky and Joe Gibeah to have.
Airbnb is three parents to answer.
When an opportunity presented itself,
there was a conference in the city,
a designer's congress,
and the hotels were full.
So if these two guys had an idea,
they said,
why don't we buy a couple of their
mattresses but them in the living room
and rent them out?
Well,
ask precisely what they did.
They offered a mattress to sleep on and
breakfast in the morning in exchange for
some money,
which they would use to pay their rent
to find customers.
They set up a website app at and
breakfast dotcom where customers could
book a mattress in their living room.
They got three customers and made $80 on
the first night of the conference.
Funny.
But we didn't think air bed and
breakfast would be a big idea.
You thought it might be able to pay the
rent until we could think of the big
idea.
One thing I learned is big ideas sound
stupid in the beginning,
Brian Chesky,
the founder and CEO of Airbnb,
well little by little they notice that
the idea,
it wasn't say far fetched in February of
2008 Nathan Bashas can architect by
profession and joins the project as the
third co founder and do with that Airbnb
was well on its way.
Oh cool.
It was not going to be easy.
The concept was nearly an embryo and
idea that many investors thought who is
completely crazy.
Think about it.
I mean it's a service to rent out a bed,
an air mattress or even a sofa in a
stranger's house.
I mean it's a pretty bizarre idea.
So we were,
all they had was their credit cards and
their own ingenuity.
Even said the other day that you would
not meet a potentially with the prime
minister of Spain,
I'm not going to shut the White House
visitors scheduled before.
I'm pressure the United States.
I don't even have a seal yet.
You hear one thing and speeches and then
you see a campaign that has the worst
kind of tactics.
Shame on you,
Barack Obama.
You can actually see Russia from land
here in Alaska.
This first,
a bit of luck came in the summer of 2008
it was the election year and the
Democratic Party and Republican Party
primaries coming to an end.
As you know,
they ended with a great convention where
each party appoints the candidates.
In this case,
the nominees when Barack Obama and John
Mccain,
wow,
do you advertise and raise funds?
They released a breakfast cereal with
the pictures of the candidates in the
market.
The best part is they caught the
attention of venture capital company.
There's only a few months later,
gave them $20,000
from that [inaudible].
That growth was unstoppable,
and today,
a decade later,
these two guys who couldn't afford their
rents have more than $3 billion each and
a pen and the ranking of the world's
richest people.
Indeed.
It's a pretty amazing example of the
American dream coming true.
The fact is that throughout this
process,
technology played a big role,
but so did the philosophy of the project
itself.
See,
as I'm sure you all know,
airbnb,
it doesn't own apartments.
It doesn't own hotels.
It's simply an intermediary in a very
synthetic way.
The idea of the company is something
like this.
Yeah.
In the wells that are many unused
resources such as empty rooms and empty
apartments.
So if instead of investing in new
resources,
we give the owners of those unused
resources the opportunity to make or
improve their income,
we can invest the money that we have in
tech
Jay,
and now airbnb is going a step further.
It wants to do the same with people's
ingenuity.
They've decided to launch an experience
service.
Allow me to explain how about some
performance and activity.
You like bike riding,
visiting monuments,
wine tasting,
whatever has airbnb offers this
experience to its customers.
What are their best known experiences is
the one you're seeing here?
It's an adventure in which you can get
to know the world of wolves.
It's creator has already raised more
than $300,000.
The truth
is that if you think about it,
connecting and exploiting under utilized
assets and people services and
creativity isn't only a great idea.
It also implies taking advantage of
resources in a very efficient way while
generating lots of benefits for society
that,
hold on a second because you're probably
thinking right now,
benefits society,
airbnb rarely Simon,
I mean the shore,
our road.
Lots of politicians out there who are
saying that we need to pass the cute or
at least limit these types of companies,
but the reality is yes,
there are benefits and I'm going to tell
you about them.
The benefits,
why the bad publicity that has been
having lately and D has brought a lot of
benefits to society as a whole.
The one,
it's making travel more affordable for
everyone.
For example,
in the u s the average rooms offered by
this platform are between 35% and 47%
cheaper than the average rooms offered
by hotels in the same city.
They have a much wider offer.
You can find almost anything that suits
your preferences on Airbnb,
even if,
I don't know if you wanted perhaps a
tree house.
Okay,
sneak.
This is a pretty inexhaustible source of
wealth,
more tourism,
more services,
more jobs.
In fact,
this platform is user spends on average
twice as much as other tourists.
Okay.
Perhaps and Andy's greatest overall
benefit has been that it's allowed
hundreds of thousands of people,
usually middle class people to become
real entrepreneurs in the tourism
sector,
thanks to Airbnb.
Many families that had free rooms or an
apartment or bought an old one to
restore it and exploited now have a new
source of income since it was launched
to the posts.
The owners who runs their rooms and
their houses cover received more than
$41 billion.
And the data,
it's very clear about this.
Most of the beneficiaries and middle
class families and yes,
don't worry.
I know that not everything is quite so
rosy.
AIRBNB has also generated some problems.
For example,
in the busiest cities,
average rent has increased and some
neighborhoods have become very busy to
the displeasure of the kneaders.
Okay.
I mean,
aren't city's supposed to be dynamic?
Is it bad for city to come alive and
create jobs and create wealth?
Isn't the real problem in how expensive
houses often driven by politics as we
saw in this video?
Well,
we're going to talk about that in a
future video as well because this is
certainly a lot to say about it,
but for now it's your turn.
What do you think should be done with
airbnb?
Well,
leave your comments below as well as in
this survey,
and I really hope you enjoyed this
video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos.
Also,
do not forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this
episode.
We're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for [inaudible].